the rumor mill is turning out this idea
that the Fantastic 4 film is going to
take place in an alternate reality where
the Fantastic 4 are the only superheroes
they'll appear in secret Wars and that's
how the Marvel Cinematic Universe is
going to bring them in if that's true
it's a terrible idea just say that
because Thor is from like Asgard a
different dimension and because of the
events of Doctor Strange 1 when doramu
almost showed up the federal government
or whoever decided to launch an
initiative where they were going to
explore whatever threats may very well
be out there and that the Fantastic 4
were the inaugural launch everything was
going fine until the events of Loki
season 1 happened the Multiverse came
back and the breadcrumb trail that the
Fantastic 4 left for themselves was
basically gone they're lost in the
Multiverse they also become the only
people who realize the full scope of
what the Council of kings are doing the
movie ends with the team captured and
then sometime before Secret Wars they
rescued and that's how the superheroes
learn everything it's not hard Marvel